In 1976, Carlo Cipolla, a professor of
economic history, derived a social law,
by which we can group people into four
categories: The first he called “the helpless”,
the second are “the intelligent”, the third are
“the bandits”, and the last are “the stupid”.
The stupid person is the most
dangerous type of person,
and in groups far more powerful than the Mafia,
the Military or Communism, Cipolla warned.
To arrive at this conclusion, we need to
understand his 5 Basic Laws of Human Stupidity.
1: Always and inevitably, everyone underestimates
the number of stupid individuals in circulation.
2: The probability that a person is stupid
is independent of any other characteristic
of that person. Education, wealth or
status have nothing to do with it.
3: A stupid person is someone who causes losses
to other people while himself deriving no gain.
4: Non-stupid people always underestimate
the damaging power of stupid people and keep
forgetting that to deal with stupid people
always turns out to be a costly mistake.
5: A stupid person is the most dangerous type
of person, even more dangerous than a bandit.
Cipolla then considers four factors of human
behavior. A person can cause benefits to others,
benefits to themselves, losses to
others and losses to themselves.
If Tom takes an action and suffers a loss,
he’s helpless. If Tom benefits himself,
while also benefiting Jerry, he’s
intelligent. If Tom helps himself,
but causes Jerry a loss, he's a bandit. And if
Tom does something that’s of no benefit to him,
but causes Jerry a loss he’s stupid.
Ineffectual people are in the center.
Let's now look at the effects
of these groups on society.
Helpless people contribute to society
but are taken advantage of by others,
especially bandits. And so
their contribution is limited.
Note that extreme altruists
or pacifists may willingly
accept a place in this category for moral reasons.
Intelligent people contribute
to society and leverage their
contributions into reciprocal benefits.
Their actions lead to a net gain to society,
which is why helpless people should
always support intelligent ones.
Bandits pursue their own self-interest
and enrich themselves, even when doing
so poses a harm to society. Helpless and
intelligent people should try to stop them.
Stupid people always contribute to a net loss
to society. But not only that. As
they do so for no obvious reason,
Their actions also frustrate,
anger and confuse everyone else.
Against major cultural trends among his fellow
intellectuals, Cipolla was convinced that men
are not equal. That some are stupid and others
are not, and that the difference is determined
by nature and nothing else. One is stupid
in the same way one is red-haired, he wrote.
Cipolla warned that the damaging potential
of the stupid person therefore depends on
the amount of stupidity inherited, as well
as their position of power in a society.
Among bureaucrats, generals and politicians one
has little difficulty in finding clear
examples of basically stupid individuals,
whose damaging capacity was alarmingly enhanced
by the position of the power they occupied.
What are your thoughts on stupidity? Are
people born or made stupid? Or is it,
as usual, more complex, and is there
an interrelationship between the two?
Share your thoughts, and read more
about Cipolla's work and amusing
essay — which originally was only intended
for friends — in the descriptions below.
If you found this helpful, check
out our other videos and subscribe.
If you want to support our work,
join us on patreon.com/sprouts.
For more information and additional
contents, visit sproutsschools.com